and that's what happens with all these
um
extreme drugs and alternative drugs we
abuse them we take them too much we
smoke too much wheat
well you know we smoke too much we smoke
too many cigarettes we just do too much
of everything
yeah we do abuse [ __ ] yeah why do you
think that is why do you think people
do you think but don't you think that
that same abuse that same
like that's also what makes people great
at things too
because that same almost the same
mindset that allows someone to abuse
drugs or abuse gambling
and become obsessed with pornography
also
is the same mindset if channeled the
right way that allows someone to become
obsessed with boxing what what
what prevents them from doing the right
thing from
the wrong thing with the same feeling
emotional intelligence yes a lot the
majority of the world don't even possess
the world
the world is not even 50 years old right
so um
this is going to be a struggle for the
next 100 years that's good until we get
that
yeah that's gonna have to be um our main
objective to develop that
yeah in order to succeed as human beings
yeah that's no truer words have ever
been said
that's what it is it's emotional
intelligence because listen
our feelings are enslaved by our
emotions and our emotions are enslaved
by our feelings
and sometimes we sort of placate those
emotions by drowning it in food
or in booze or in gambling or sex or
anything that conditions
and then we turn that into memories
yeah and then we become enslaved to our
memories yeah it never stops
right we that's who we are we are an
alcoholic
we are allowed yes we could stop from
coming that's just like
um we learned um alcoholics anonymous
yeah so we can learn from that so that's
why they learn from that so now it's not
hopeless anymore right
that's why it's so hard for people
because they have a memory of all the
things they've done
that's wrong and they do it all the time
and that becomes who they think they are
until they start changing the picture
right it's all about changing the
channel you know right
change their channel in life well that's
what's so exciting about you with this
new chapter of your life you've just
completely changed who you are you went
from
pot smoking mike tyson who's running
tyson ranch who's this real nice guy to
hang around with
doing hot boxing with mike tyson fun to
be with
everything's great and all of a sudden
you shift right back into mike tyson
the murderer again well it's just that
um
as i said earlier today if we knew who
we were
we'd be very limited you know
we don't know who we are we don't know
you don't know what you might do
tomorrow when you wake up
it's true you might are you married yeah
well listen you might
get married again you know you might go
crazy
yeah you might take out a new job no
yeah well that's one of the exciting
things about life right i mean this has
to be an exciting time for you
to make this big switch yeah i think
about that too
but i think about a lot i think about a
lot like you know i'm 54
and that um i'm not going to be here
much longer and if when i go in my love
to see my wife and kids again the
friends that i loved all my life my
mother go see them again i started
thinking about that
you know you know you know when we think
about it
this guy's this guy's book what to say
every
one beat away from and turn our internal
journey some guy sent me that book
and i said wow this is pretty cool
because it's true we're only one
heartbeat away from dying yeah and going
on that long ride of
not knowing yeah a feeling cause that's
when i was on the toad
dmt is all about feeling yeah the feel
makes the reality